tickets for the in-person sin Week
events are available through the end of
January don't miss out on your chance to
join the sin crew and the sin club for
delicious food sinful movie watching and
more the live event is in Nashville this
March check the link in the video
description for all the details
[Music]
why are we waiting in line for food Rick
asked this instead of the very obvious
why are we waiting in this wildly
inefficient line for food look any good
business should have a grasp of basic Q
Management systems and in a space this
can find your basic hardly structured
cue just isn't going to cut it at the
very least this asteroid should have
barriers in snake formation to maximize
the lateral space but really this calls
for an e-ticketing system where an order
is placed the customer returns to their
vehicle and is called up once their food
is ready ideally considering everyone is
driving here anyway a multi-window
drive-through situation would be the
dream but come on guys it's just a
cartoon I'm not that nitpicky brick
you're gonna spoil your appetite it's a
weird way to say I'm gonna stop being
hungry by eating food right out of the
gate Rick would be a season two episode
of Rick and Morty at TV since what a
wonderful thing to say I was merely
inspired by the wonderful thing you said
the comment section of every TV sends
video somehow makes it into the episode
now for those of you who haven't paused
I know you're the ones that have been
leaving the comments and I see what you
write and I would just like to say thank
thank you your adoration for my
brilliantly executed wit and expertly
crafted comedy stylings is obviously
expected but still appreciated
nonetheless so the sin is always is me
being excellent at TV since well at
least the mystery of the long line has
been solved what kind of [ __ ] go to
a food truck to order this many
um burrito sub witches how nice it will
be for you to eat what you are willing
to stand in line for so much sooner
trying to incept the idea into someone's
head that they should be happy about the
way you've treated them because of how
you feel about it I'm not sure which
vehicle warning light this is but I'm
sure it's one of them dear fellow
littering the ground with your unwrapped
lettuce filled
um Hot Pockets
birthday chainmail that is this
ineffective against a [ __ ] sword
whoa wait a minute rewind that without a
word of warning sir David of Mitchell is
either teleported out of the blue by an
external Force causing him to drop the
food or he deliberately drops the food
and teleports them back to the sun
either way what the [ __ ] was the point
of this trip if all the food has been
left behind why did Rick put this portal
on the floor we've seen portals appear
out of thin air many times so it's not
like they require a physical surface
like portal portals if he'd used it
normally then he and Morty could have
run through it without stopping six
seasons six seasons this has been
bugging me our lives are never ending
but not even in the dumb vampire way
where after a while you hate it well
that's a pretty bold statement to make
are you speaking on behalf of everyone
even what looks like peasants who don't
get fancy armor and swords and how can
this be something you truly know until
you've lived for millions of years and
are endlessly suffocating through the
heat death of the universe
it is the home of the solar scepter
around which all worlds revolve The Men
Who keep it safe are admired by all and
live as God admired by all and how the
[ __ ] is Morty only just hearing about
them we'll learn that there are people
living on all the planets of the solar
system all of whom are aware of the sun
nights yet the most populated planet in
the solar system hasn't got a clue it's
a terrific and painful sacrifice we all
make for the most important and Powerful
job in the universe careful how you're
throwing the word Universe around sir
you're not even the best drummer in the
Beatles wait I may have my star star
punchlines confused no no the sword has
already seen blade and loved it you'll
be fine introducing us to a larger
sentient blade doesn't make it any less
of a recycled concept I'm a drunk I'm a
psychopath I'm a murderer rejected lines
from Meredith Brooks 1997 hit song
somehow make their way into this episode
the show's acting like Morty's more
upset by the singing of these Knights
than he is by the fact that they only
have honey to put on their pancakes
Cherry Beth and summer all appear to be
chewing and swallowing despite having a
plate of intact pancakes why is
breakfast such a challenge for this show
yeah so there you have it Traditions
suck ass in your most Foundation
National beliefs are total [ __ ]
Morty's lecture though strikingly
similar to the experience of taking a
college-level history course for some
reason includes a diagram that presents
all of the planets on the same orbital
ellipse and a room full of space
Travelers lets him get away with this I
just use your computer phone to search
despair [ __ ] you did this phone is
clearly on the history of New York
podcast and even if the rim prices there
are bad enough to have this pop up when
you search despair it's certainly not
the first hit or even above the site
with the demotivational posters so Rick
and Morty needs spacesuits on the moon
are we saying that the asteroid at the
start of the show had a [ __ ]
atmosphere haven't you seen like all of
the universes exactly so why would I
hang out on Pluto that's some Jerry
League oh you take that back Pluto has
had a rough time enough as it is without
that sort of slander the Knights of the
sun plan to protect Mercury from this
chaos the mercurians choose to
ceremonially cut off their right breast
instead of their and I don't know if
this was a low-key way to raise
awareness for breast cancer in both
women and men but that's certainly the
reason I'm pointing it out so I'm
removing Us in because the animators
gave me the opportunity to do so but
also the animators let this car migrate
from the left in this shot to the right
in this shot so I have to Addison again
because they gave me the opportunity to
do so
it's all you pal this fireworks don't I
have like authority over the sons of the
Moon meeting looks like Morty went to
the King visera School of asserting your
Authority Santa what the hell is that
and the Earl of Earth God damn it the
Earl of Earth has no idea who Santa is
how can you be the Earl of Earth and not
understand the true meaning of Christmas
Venus questions the legitimacy of this
king's Authority I've been trying to put
my finger on why this episode isn't
quite Landing for me and then this line
suddenly hit me like an unannounced
10-year time Jump I think the episode
shot for Game of Thrones but
accidentally landed in House of the
Dragon now there's a chance that they
sabotage their own episode as a meadow
way to have a pop at how boring the
throne's concept is in and of itself but
that would be like me publishing this
video without any of the punch lines and
I get accused of doing that enough as it
is
writers realized there was no British
noble title that began with the letter N
so they just gave Neptune a silly voice
and called it a day we won't dare Play
the song out of fear of angering some
pink guy but Goodbye Blue Sky is
currently soundtracking the solar War so
the sin as always is Ruby Tuesday is Ye
Olde neutral zone on the moon if so why
are the sons of the Moon okay with this
and if it's because the sons of the Moon
moved all their operations to the sun
why haven't we started referring to them
as the sons of the sun Santa Claus is
not looking on the bright side of life
in this scene
wow
techno explaining your type's position
type no explaining your war crimes
position what is this
we weren't thinking it was vat of acid
again until you brought it up then we
did think it was bad of acid again
because you brought it up then we
thought it was less about doing that of
acid again and more about doing
self-referential callbacks because you
think we love that then we thought maybe
we'd like it if you did do that of acid
again because as it turns out we might
love that then we thought maybe vat of
acid again was just a metaphor for
trying to love again after being burned
one too many times then we thought
what's that of acid again got to do with
it who needs a bad when a vat can be
broken Morty this family's got enough
clones and robots in it I'm not sure if
Rick is using in it as an American way
to confirm that one or more of their
family members are robots or if he's
using the British sling in it is a bit
of filler to elicit agreement for Morty
but what I do know is that this episode
has far too many not funny jokes in it
living on the sun has turned our veins
into triple bonded carbon so try this
tail on for size more Daniel we can't do
D well sure triple plotted veins will do
the trick but didn't you guys say you
were mortal and only died when you chose
to wouldn't that be a pretty solid
defense as well also so who while on a
sun adulterated heroine binge stops for
any amount of time to confirm the
composition of their veins I'll give you
a fake tick with three layers of fail
safes yeah but if two of those
fail-safes start rubbing against each
other it could really undermine the
whole Endeavor also why not just let
Morty cut his dick off and then grow it
back for him later not that I want to
see this I'm just saying we've seen Rick
grow parts of bodies clone entire bodies
and change the entire genetic makeup of
a species multiple times growing back
one penis should be a cakewalk we're
gonna make you so fake buddy here's the
thing Rick said to his grandson in this
episode
oh sir the Knights of the sun are once
more everyone starts destroying their
weapons as soon as the sun signal starts
without confirming that all of their
enemies are doing the same or that peace
is actually at hand this is like ending
your crime spree and Gotham after seeing
the bat signal without confirming that
Batman isn't just tied up with the joker
or some okay it's not exactly like that
but at some point the criminals of
Gotham should realize that the [ __ ]
bat signal doesn't mean for them and if
Batman is chasing after Petty thieves
then he should look at where he's
dedicating his resources I mean why does
he even attend bank robberies in
progress all the [ __ ] money is
insured anyway the [ __ ] does the bank
here yeah yeah I know the money will get
used for drugs and weapons and stuff but
it's a glorified NightLight really
inspiring that much fear and hardened
criminals what was I saying again
did you recover disguiser really need
that very visual notification that it's
been turned off also why can this
hologram be deactivated at the touch of
a button but not reactivated at the
touch of a button and after Morty goes
through the scanner whoa a sunspot what
something something Morty's pixelated
clone slinkies down the stairs improv
the rest is how I imagine the scene was
written okay we'll go on through and of
course by prosthetic we mean witchcraft
a little witch is funny and all but this
was clearly designed for a humorous
reveal and not to actually fool anyone
I'm not even sure why Morty's pretending
this one was gonna work we even checked
with a royal label to ensure it was real
son not just them hiding beneath in a
bat of fake Sun show thinks it's funny
that it was vatavacet again this entire
time showing favoritism coming right up
three Illusions how about 10 years in
jail if you were about to arrest him for
trafficking these creatures did you have
to open with ordering some to be eaten
they get their poor little heads
punctured also that you could have your
big gotcha moment you selfish bastard
this is like [ __ ] Batman deciding to
disappear on Jim Gordon mid-sens just so
hey don't you ding me off I've got
things to say hey stop with the bams I'm
not done yet
[Music]
now just cut off your penises and throw
them into the sun
not not quite my temple this guy's the
king of the sun
we are now the night
tonight
what is this fat of acid again I
understood that reference come on Morty
stop asking what you're asking and let's
just get back to our crisis by all means
Dr Selden speak I admit I wanted what
you once had Brotherhood tradition
stability purpose I just didn't want to
cut my dick off for it he's beginning to
believe
the walkway needs those nights those
nights need a king and that King needs
no dick but you're not paying yeah go
tell everybody your reward's gonna be
cutting off your own
okay well then I changed my answer to
just ignoring the question